this morning Israel is the only country
praising President Trump for recognizing
Jerusalem as Israel's capital there are
fiery protests in the nearby West Bank
barracks foreign ministry summoned the
US ambassador Francis president says he
disapproves of this move and Saudi
Arabia called it unjustified and
irresponsible will go to the West Bank
city of Bethlehem in just a moment but
first market Brennan is at the White
House with the latest on this story
Margaret good morning good morning well
there is some confusion about exactly
what President Trump meant when he said
the u.s. recognizes Israeli sovereignty
in Jerusalem today the Secretary of
State emphasized that doesn't mean the
final status of the contested city has
been decided on saying that's still up
for negotiation this is nothing more or
less than a recognition of reality it is
also the right thing to do president
Trump broke with seven decades of US
policy and the advice of virtually every
other country this decision is not
intended in any way to reflect a
departure from our strong commitment to
facilitate a lasting peace agreement he
insisted the unilateral decision to
recognize Jerusalem as the Israeli
capital would not impede the peace
process led by son-in-law Jerry Kushner
but the president made no concessions to
the Palestinians who also claimed the
holy city saying that the US would only
support a future Palestinian state if
Israel agrees to it while previous
presidents have made this a major
campaign promise they failed to deliver
today I am delivering the campaign
promise to move the embassy was popular
with evangelical Christian voters
prompting vice president Mike Pence and
UN Ambassador nikki Haley to urge him to
do it but secretaries Madison Tillerson
cautioned it could hurt US security
interests last night former CIA director
John Brennan called the decision
reckless and irresponsible if there's
bloodshed on this I think people will
need to look at
what mr. Trump did and decided and
whether or not that bloodshed could have
been avoided it was in a small meeting
last Monday that President Trump
informed his team of his decision I'm
told he was insistent Secretary's mattes
and Tillerson asked for more time to
roll out security precautions they were
given one week Noora some allies were
told just the day before really
important reporting there Margaret thank
you so much